part of that thousand dollar emergency
funds
but there is going to be a level of
angst and urgency which makes people go
through the baby steps maybe step two
that much faster because they're like oh
my gosh I feel like if something were to
happen but the truth is Right majority
of emergencies that we see uh whether
it's new tires on a car you know
whatever it is most of it is under a
thousand dollars so majority of it is
and if not all you do is you pause the
debt snowball stay current on everything
pile up some cash with what you need
fixed and fix it and so just having the
idea that there's going to be no debt
the debt is not an option you find a way
to get through it all you find a way
like you really do so if it's the car
that's breaking down you go and get
three options and you fix the small part
that you can to get a truck along to you
save up to fix the rest I mean you just
you figure you figure it out and so the
problem is that debt has just become
such a safety net for people that
mentally you can't even imagine you know
not having the credit card